You know the suit wasn't necessary.
Blair. Please. Johnny is my best friend.
He's got a stake in this.
So if I'm doing it, I'm doing it right.
Now, let's start with the basics.
Would you classify your marriage as sexually
satisfying? What?
How often would you say you have
intercourse?
That's none of your goddamn business.
Look, why don't we just
stick- every six months?
Every six months?
And what about anal, dude?
Jesus Christ.
We do like the room to be clean.
Yeah.
She said yes.
Hilarious. Okay, now I want you to turn to
each other and say the meanest thing you can
think of.
Ted, why don't you ask them something
productive, like how they met.
What originally drew them to each other?
All right. Um, Maddie, what, uh, originally
attracted you to Susan?
Her innocence.
Oh. Okay.
Uh, what I thought, uh, I already wrote.
It's okay.
It's fine. Uh, Susan.
His heart.
When Maddie and I first met, he bought us
tickets to see Simon and Garfunkel.
It was a Friday, and he'd been working since
6 a.m.
Poor Maddie was so tired.
Well, if there's any cure for being tired,
it's Simon and Garfunkel.
We'd never seen him up close.
So when we got there, Maddie realized that
Garfunkel was a man, so we had to leave.
Wait, why?
Two men shouldn't be singing harmony.
Dad, I thought you liked Hall and Oates.
That's different.
Why? Because they sing in unison, or they
take turns one and then the other one.
That's okay.
What about Crosby, Stills and Nash?
They're all right for now, but I'm keeping my
eye on them.
You're a complicated man.
I'm still waiting for the heart part.
Well, we got in the car and Maddie drove
home, and he got his record player, and he
took me to Boston Common, and we had a
picnic on the lawn while we listened to
Sonny and Cher.
And he bought me a rose, and he danced with
me right there on the grass.
You remember that? Of course I do.
Maddie. You did that?
Yeah.
It was beautiful.
She was this wicked smart college girl, and
I wanted to impress her.
See, I'm a good guy.
That prick f*** shrink was way off, so f***
everybody.
Mom, I didn't know you went to college.
Yeah. Me neither.
What did you study?
Well, I, uh, I was going to teach.
You were going to be a teacher.
Susan. That's amazing.
I'd gotten my credentials, and I was all
ready to apply for a job, and then I got
married.
Why couldn't you do both?
Well, it just didn't seem practical with the
groceries and the laundry and.
Well, I mean, have you ever thought of going
back to it? I think you'd be great.
Oh, no.
No, that was a long time ago.
No, I couldn't.
Susan, I really think you could do this.
Jesus. She said she's not interested.
Should I make some chocolate milk?
Oh, yeah. Chocolate milk.
Chocolate milk.
No, Susan, for God's sake.
Therapy over. We're doing chocolate milk now
. Guys.
Come on. This woman does everything for all
of us in this house, and nobody ever does a
goddamn thing for her.
And now she's sitting here telling us
something that's important.
That's horse
sh*t. I do a ton of stuff.
You?
What do you do for Susan?
I pay for everything she owns and eats.
Okay, how about we all just sit with what
Maddie just said while Susan gets on that
chocolate milk?
I'll get that for you.
Well, I think I just proved my point that
this marriage is perfect.
Yeesh, I couldn't say this in front of him,
but they were both clearly molested.
Guys, believe it or not, I think we did
great.
Really?
Yeah. We just found out Susan has no identity
outside this family.
I mean, she's a wife, she's a mother.
But that's it.
She could be so much more.
And it's so obvious that deep down, she
wants to be.
You got all that from her saying she does
anal, man.
You should be the pretend therapist.
I mean, I hear you, Blair, but what are we
supposed to do?
I don't know yet, but somehow we got to help
her find her voice. I mean, we're the only
ones that can do it.
Couldn't agree more, Blair.
Delusional narcissist.
Excuse me.
Note to self.
Stop saying what you write.